well the queen is to mysticia's
buckingham palace garden parties a
mainstay of the royal calendar in
another
slightly worrying sign that we're
drawing ever closer to a major
transition in our monarchy the
journalist and author tina brown has for
decades had incredible access and
insight into the royal family and her
new book the palace papers it's packed
with juicy revelations and dana joyce
well lovely to see you it's lovely to
see you and what an excitement to see
brian cox in the green room i mean the
legend a legend i miss my favorite tv
character oh my god i'm a junkie i just
logan roy i actually am not going to
tell him i have a whatsapp chat group
with my sons where i'm logan i said
means as logan and they all they
actually all want to be roman they want
to be the fun one um but we're going to
speak to brian obviously in a moment
tina what a book this is i don't think
you can beat your dino one this is
better in a way because it's so
multi-faceted covers so many people and
right now there's a really i think
massive question mark when you see the
queen missing all the summer garden
parties you know she's frail she's 96
she's lost phillip she's got all this
stuff going on with her health you think
we're going to have to contemplate the
unthinkable you know for you and me our
entire lives
we've only had one monarch and if she
does leave us what happens next
it's a it's a very worrying moment it's
a perilous moment i mean she's been on
the money for 17 years it's amazing i
mean we just can't imagine life without
her and i think it's going to be a
massive kind of tsunami of you know
grief and instability in this country a
kind of identity crisis i don't think we
know how to be british anymore without
the queen it will be a remarkable moment
it will be and i think for charles it's
it's a challenge he's gonna he's gonna
have to be the one now to right this
ship and just say up to the challenge i
mean from reading your book it's so many
great stories about them all and i think
you've captured from what i know about a
lot of the personalities you've captured
them so well charles has been the the
king in waiting for so long
is he up for this massive challenge well
it's interesting if he were ever to
become king this is the moment because
you know his passions for
conservation and climate change concerns
all of that stuff is actually now
absolutely in sync with his own people
so he's kind of come into his own moment
of time and he's going to have to be a
transitional monarch he hasn't got a
great deal of time and his role is going
to have to really be to to modernize and
steer the ship to be ready for williams
his trump card to me actually is camilla
who i know well i really like her
personally i think she's been the one
calming constant in his life actually
but we're already reading that prince
harry
is planning with his book coming out
this year which may ruin the entire
platinum jubilee that his book may be
targeting camilla as a kind of revenge
for
what he perceives his father did to his
mother there's a great deal of concern
that that's what he will do
and i hope he doesn't because actually
i understand his bitterness because of
the whole back story but camilla has
transformed charles i mean the man looks
completely different a friend of mine
who actually had dinner recently with
them
charles was actually you know stayed
longer downstairs and camilla and he
said he'd never seen a man so happily
take two stairs at a time
to go and see his wife upstairs the man
is just unapologetically happy and and
that makes a difference to him you know
talking of happiness is prince harry
happy i mean look my views about him and
meghan markle are pretty well known i'm
not going to labor the point you do lots
of fascinating research in your book
about this i mean you're pretty scathing
about megan i mean you're sympathetic in
some ways but you're quite scared i
don't think i am scathing about her
actually i feel that i've got inside
that situation in a way that has a lot
of many dimensions sum it up simply
megan simply
didn't realize didn't understand
how different the monarchy is from the
inside to what it looks like from the
outside from the outside it's palaces
it's global tours it's being you know
adored it's being one of the most famous
people in the world from inside you know
it can be really dull it is grunt work
but she gave it 18 months i mean i just
i just can't buy this i think she's
genuinely planned the whole thing i
think she thought i'll come in hoover up
this prince yank him back to california
and become the new angelina and brad
pitt i think she thought honestly that
she could
play a different kind of of princess
that she could actually i don't think
she went in there thinking i'm going to
snatch harry out of there i think she
thought she was going to be
uh able to be this global humanitarian
princess the problem was
that harry was actually by that time
sixth in line to the throne
he's not although he's a global
superstar inside the palace hierarchy
he's not really such a big deal i mean i
don't really have a place if they want
to go and live in california and lead
the life of one of the everyone should
be allowed to lead the lies they want to
leave no one can force them to do what
they do my central problem with the
situation now is that they want to keep
their royal titles which make them all
the money from netflix spotify and so on
they don't want to do any of the duty
that comes with the titles and they want
to go on national television quite
regularly and trash the institution of
the monarchy and the royal families a
bunch of callus races which causes
incalculable damage and we see in the
commonwealth now when they're going on
these tours and getting some adverse
reaction a lot of that comes back to
meghan markle the first non-white member
of the royal family calling them a bunch
of racists not saying who it was well i
mean i think that actually that harry is
on a pretty good mojo right now i mean
because he started
he looks well you know i did think that
actually for a while but i do think just
recently he's got his mojo back i think
that invictus that he invented was a
brilliance
i mean this is his legacy and actually
for harry that should be his complete
focus and brown but he doesn't talk to
his brother william right that's pretty
clear in the book very unhappy situation
between him and his brother and actually
i think it's weakening for william as
much as it is for harry not to have that
fraternal bond they were a great team
like we've lost this guy he doesn't look
that happy to me someone who else is not
remotely happy will be prince andrew and
many will say well he shouldn't be the
queen i thought was remarkable at
phillips memorial service that she
wanted andrew to walk down the aisle
with him it was a really big statement
by the queen i mean i thought misguided
but actually other people thought it's
her son and it was his father he was
honoring what did you think well i mean
what is so fascinating about the queen
is where he's always been able to
compartmentalize sovereign hrh you know
the queen
from
mother grandmother and a private world
and actually one of the things that i
learned during this piece is that in the
family they all know who they're going
to see are they going to see the
sovereign because they're going to talk
about matters of you know matters of
import to them or is it mummy or is it
mummy and granny now like any big ceo
like logan roy's family
i mean they like to snip through
sometimes i mean he thinks he's
dysfunctional logan roy wait did you see
the royals right exactly but actually it
all works just the same as succession i
mean i mean there's some fantastic
descriptions of public figures in your
book tina who's this who you described
as an editorial swashbuckler an 800
pound gorilla of british tv and the
young lord of misrule who reveled in
transgression
any clues stand up piers morgan it is
you it is you i mean listen you were the
great you were the great sort of prince
of the 90s pierce i mean listen the word
list of the 90s i mean the prince of the
night i mean you were unbelievable and
actually i still believe that your
diaries
are
absolutely amazing classic and i want to
see them you know on ice and and singing
and dancing
maybe you know i i think
they are a portrait of an age the 90s
which are unbelievable one of the most
amazing stories you tell in that diary
is how when princess diana brought
prince william no you went to lunch at
kensington with william diana and prince
i mean think about it can you two hours
of everything two hours and what struck
me william was 13 and she told him
everything everything absolutely
everything well that was what's so
incredible i mean can you imagine today
i hope it might happen but i i suspect
it won't that the duchess of cambridge
would invite you and your peers over to
london
if you're watching uh your role of
highness i am available i think i'm
actually sending their kids to one of
the schools that my my kids went to yeah
but it was an ask me anything lunch
right now you asked her anything you
wanted you spend a lot of time in
america uh and as i as do i prince
charles is trying to woo his american
fans this has happened to yesterday in
fact he went to a school in south london
and was shown how to throw an american
football
so before we show it look at tom brady
throwing one
sometimes i could protect it
now
actually not bad i mean i just thought
that was good
given his age and lack of experience uh
you know who could have done that
brilliantly is prince harry because i
was actually told which is very
interesting that prince harry the reason
that he was such a great soldier such a
great shot he has perfect hand-eye
coordination yeah he is brilliant at
throwing balls out he said well let's
send on a happy note with prince harry
uh tina brown the palace it's a riveting
read honestly i love the diner book i
love this one i could i'm going to read
it thoroughly gorge on it not least
about myself uh good luck with the book
lovely to see you thank you pierce good
luck with this show thank you
in the studio